well Ashington is in our network and I
think for anybody else it's the most
sustainable in the most state-of-the-art
plant it is an proof of our commitment
to the UK market we have about 3,500
employees it is our single largest
market within the European continent so
this is a sign of making the Dulux dog
happy in the UK and keeping it alive and
kicking so we were very proud of opening
it because it shows a real boost and it
supports our strength into the UK market
as a leader here in the country you've
invested something like 100 million
euros in this facility I believe clearly
you're not too concerned about brexit
well we are concern about brexit to get
clarity on how it's being done I mean we
are a bit concerned around the
uncertainty and what it does to consumer
confidence as you see it in many
non-food sectors in the country but to
be honest the UK market for us is such
an important market that the Ashington
plant is really focused on the local
market here for us what would be really
a comfort giving is as sooner we know
what shape the brexit is going to take
because then as a large multinational
company we can plan around it so we are
a bit agnostic around which scenario it
takes as long as we have some certainty
on how it's going to shape out what are
the kind of concerns that you'd like to
see specifically addressed well
obviously anything that makes it
difficult to get products in or out or
complicated would be a bit hampering but
for us as a large domestic player for
for paints and coatings in the UK most
of what comes out of our Ashington unit
and the other sides is for domestic use
here in the UK so we are more concerned
around what does it bring in across the
border how difficult does it go but
again I would say the sooner we have
clarity on how it is the sooner we can
start planning around how to deal with
it so a British consumers likely to be
facing domestic consumers likely to be
facing increases in the price of Dulux
paint I think for the large extent I
think in the industry and for
the suppliers I think that it's
increasingly has been part of the
pricing and then you have the overlay of
all sorts of other commercial activities
so I don't think there should be a big
change to be expected in the market here
I'm looking ahead to 2018 how do you see
consumer confidence more broadly I mean
we've talked about the UK but what about
elsewhere in the world oh it's really
around the world you have every shade
and every version of consumer confidence
or lack thereof I would say if I look at
China which is a key market for us and
we'll be very successful there the
consumer confidence even from the middle
class but also higher up is very strong
so we see an enormous demand for our
products in Europe continental Europe
the confidence seems to have come back
which has been was a way for many many
years before so that's positive as I say
the UK consumer looks a little bit to be
in a wait-and-see mode another big
market for us is Latin America Brazil
notably is a big country for us there it
has stabilized but we're still still
hoping for a much stronger up there and
so you have every as you would imagine
every version of confidence around the
globe